et là j'ai fait mon premier film qui
s'appelle l'a fait aux choux
[Musique]
j'aurais exactement 84 points le 1er
juillet prochain
[Musique]
pourriez-vous nous dire par quel chemin
vous êtes entré dans cette industrie à
leur naissance du cinéma et comment vous
en êtes arrivé à devenir metteur en
scène pour cet art nouveau
alors je vous dirais que j'ai été obligé
de travailler gagner ma vie et que je
suis rentré comme secrétaire dans les
établissements guo qui n'était pas
encore dû rester là bisman gourmand mais
enfin où la photographie était un grand
succès à ce moment là on ne connaissait
pas encore le cinéma
[Musique]
au bout de quelques temps nous avons
reçu la visite de louis et auguste
lumière est il temps habiter gaumont à
une soirée qu'il donnait sans lui dire
qu'elle était calé texte
cette soirée alors j'étais là ils m'ont
dit mademoiselle alice voulez vous
assistez aussi évidemment j'ai accepté
avec grand plaisir
la lumière s'est éteinte il nous avons
vu apparaître sur l'écran des choses qui
sont devenues classiques c'est-à-dire
l'arroseur arrosé les sorties de de leur
lancer une partie de cartes je ne me
souviens pas exactement quoi
enfin c'était la naissance du cinéma et
j'ai demandé à gourmand la permission
terre quelques saynètes et de les mettre
en scène on évalue wizo c'est une
affaire de jeunes filles je veux bien la
condition surtout ça n'empiète pas sur
votre courrier alors j'arrivais à 8
heures du matin chez gaumont jeu
dépouillé le courrier je le distribue et
ses râles puis je m'en allais à côté des
étés travaux photographiques
il y avait un intérêt celui mains nues
n'est ce pas avec une petite terrasse
bitumées et c'est là dessus que nous
avons commencé avec mon opérateur mon
caméraman et quand on critique les
premiers films ça me fait toujours mal
au coeur parce que si les gens avaient
vu dans quelles conditions l'occasion et
là j'ai fait mon premier film qui
s'appelle la paix au chaud
[Musique]
nous avons trouvé par exemple la façon
de tourner le film à l'envers
nous avons fait la maison qui tombait
qui se reconstruisait lui-même le le
gourmand qui allaient danser un
pâtissier qui a avalé trop de gâteaux
qui les rendait intact c'est ensuite il
m'a indiqué comment on pouvait prendre
des des personnages plus loin ou plus
près pour les faire petits et grands
c'est comme ça que nous avons trouvé des
uns après les autres des petites choses
intéressantes
êtes vous resté longtemps à faire des
films pour gaumont ou au contraire avec
violence en sueur est séchée comment
jusqu'à ce que le studio se bâtissent en
ce moment là ça devenait intéressant et
on m'a fort disputée la direction et
j'ai continué et petit à petit au bout
de quelques temps on m'a donné deux
assistants dont vous connaissez les noms
probablement arnaud ricoux jan j'ai fait
un des premiers films de grande longueur
c'est grand c'est important n'est ce pas
ça a été la passion ça a été du reste un
des derniers que j'ai fait c'est comment
mon mari a été envoyé en amérique pour
représenter le crown of thorns lui est
naturellement je les ai suivis
et nous avons fait surtout beaucoup de
ce film cowboys pour commencer c'était
la grande mode à ce moment là j'ai même
eu des combats là au studio qui nous
enlever nos décors et en quarts du temps
avec un petit chevaux qui sautait
partout et ensuite je suis allé à
washington où j'ai pris avec le 15e de
cavalerie gpo des films sur les anciens
les combats qui avaient eu lieu au
moment de la sécession et c est ce que
vous aviez eu à cette époque des
contacts avec les premières
personnalités du cinéma américain et 100
ans certainement faisait à peu près tous
cas nuit et ses films
ont-ils disparu ou au contraire est il
possible d'en retrouver la 3g est
retrouvé dans les catalogues
oui des grands musées comme le musée
d'art moderne moderne n'est ce pas que
comme la librairie du congrès j'ai
retrouvé tous mes films c'est là où je
les ai retrouvés les mon nom figure
comme un metteur en scène
donc ces films existent toujours je ne
sais pas s'ils existent je n'ai pas pu
m'en procurer jusqu'à présent sur vous
n'avez pas repris en france une activité
cinéma j'ai essayé mais je n'ai pas
réussi
[Musique]